es war der moment auf den die ukraine so
lange gewartet hatte der moment der im
vorfeld so viel diskutiert und für so
viel aufregung gesorgt hatte olaf scholz
traf wolodimir selensky in kiew
gemeinsam mit emanuel makro mario draghi
und klaus johannis hatt er den scholz
hat scholz den horror des krieges
besichtigt es sollte mehr als nur ein
reiner fototermin werden das hatte
scholz im vorfeld angekündigt und das
war es am ende dann auch
er kommt mit einer tasche ohne koffer
und am ende gibt's dann natürlich doch
ein foto olaf scholz in der ukraine mit
italiens ministerpräsident draghi und
frankreichs präsident macau im
kriegsgebiet die drei staats- und
regierungschefs wollen dem ukrainischen
präsidenten
prominenz die den rücken stärken alle
fragen sich was hat der kanzler da in
seiner tasche was bringt er den ukrainer
ist überhaupt etwas drin für sie
ob im sonderzug nach kiew weil der
ankunft im hotel oder beim treffen mit
den drei präsidenten
immer mit dabei ist die schwarze kanzler
tasche von olaf scholz was auffällt so
lenz die wie gewohnt im grünen militär t
shirt hemdsärmlig er ist im krieg die
anderen im anzug doch was haben sie im
gepäck für den ukrainischen präsidenten
der auch deutliche zu sagen kauft und
auf waffenlieferungen sein fazit am ende
des historischen besuchs
[Musik]
heute ist ein wahrhaft historischer tag
die ukraine hat die unterstützung von
gleich vier mächtigen europäischen
staaten gespürt vor allem für unseren
beitritt zur europäischen union italien
rumänien frankreich und deutschland
stehen an unserer seite alle vier staats
und regierungschefs unterstützten die
kandidatur der ukraine natürlich müssen
alle verfahren eingehalten werden und
alle eu mitgliedstaaten müssen sich
anschließend aber bei unserem heutigen
treffen wurde ein großer schritt nach
vorn gemacht für mich war es wichtig von
den staats und regierungschefs noch
etwas grundlegendes zu hören sie sind
sich einig dass das ende des krieges und
der frieden für die ukraine genauso sein
müssen wie die ukraine es sich vorstellt
waffen hat scholz nur wenige in seiner
tasche immerhin ein hochmodernes
luftabwehrsystem bestätigte lenski am
abend ein paar zusagen für den
präsidenten und am ende gibt es dann
doch noch ein foto stützt die ukraine
auch mit der lieferung von waffen- und
wir werden das weiterhin tun solange die
ukraine unsere unterstützung bemüht ein
schwieriger besuch mit großen
erwartungen und kleiner tasche
tja kleine tasche große erwartungen
schauen wir direkt zur paul ronzheimer
nach kiew paul schönen guten morgen also
die erwartungen waren wirklich hoch im
vorfeld konnte scholz die in irgendeiner
form erfüllen
der bundeskanzler konnte die erwarte und
zumindest teilweise erfüllen es ging ja
auch um die eu-beitrittsperspektive und
da gab s ein klares zeichen ein klares
signal von deutschland und frankreich
dass man das will dass man zumindest
dieses eu beitritts verfahren eröffnet
und das ist etwas was natürlich hier
positiv begleitet wird sowohl von der
politischen elite des landes aber auch
von den menschen auf der straße aber und
jetzt kommt das große aber die frage
wenn man sich auf deutschland fokussiert
ist schon wie viele waffen kommen jetzt
an da war olaf scholz nicht klar also
hat keine neuen waffensysteme dort
bekannt gegeben er hat nicht gesagt dass
deutschland noch mal mehr liefern als
ursprünglich gesagt da bleibt bei der
linie die ja seit den vergangenen wochen
und monaten hat und das ist etwas was
dann wiederum eher kritisch begleitet
wird aus der ukrainischen perspektive
wir wollen noch mal auf einen moment
schauen der doch für irritationen
gesorgt hat denn direkt tatsächlich
nachdem die drei staatschefs im hotel
angekommen waren gab es erstmal luft
als die vier regierungschefs in kiew
ankamen will die ankunft übrigens mit
dem beginn des luftraums zusammen wir
hören
in diesem moment sirenenalarm in kiew
während der bundeskanzler hier in der
stadt es regiert russland hat eine
situation geschaffen in der jeder dieses
jahr ihnen hören konnte um eine
angespannte atmosphäre zu schaffen aber
niemand hatte angst und es hat uns nur
dazu inspiriert so genau wie möglich zu
sein und für unsere interessen zu
verhandeln für alle ukraine und für alle
in europa
paula lenski also dieser luftalarm alles
andere als ein zufall
nun ja also das sage ich jetzt nicht zu
beurteilen wie der zustande gekommen ist
es gibt ja immer wieder luftalarm drei
vier fünf mal am tag auch gestern nacht
wieder also
unklar welchen gefahrenlage ist dort
wirklich gegeben hat denn es ist so wenn
im luftraum eine rakete auftaucht oder
wenn es den den versuch gibt der russen
etwas zu bombardieren im land in dieser
richtung auch dann kann es schon
sirenenanlagen geben es wurde kein ziel
gestern morgen oder gestern mittag in
kiew betroffen und auch die delegation
bzw der bundeskanzler sind sehr
entspannt geblieben als das passierte
muss man sagen und sind kurze zeit
danach ja auch den richtung ihr team
gefahren mit ihren autos vom hotel also
vom zentrum kiews
aussprechen wir direkt mal über diesen
besuch in wien paul ich muss sagen also
so angefasst so emotional habe ich olaf
scholz tatsächlich seiten gesehen
absolut wir haben ja oder schotter sehr
nah begleitet den alpinen als er durch
diese ruin muss man ja sagen gelaufen
ist und man hat es in seinen augen
gesehen wie sehr ihn das studiert hat er
war als bürgermeister und dann als
finanzminister
noch nie in so einem kriegsgebiet so
etwas hatte er möglicherweise in seinem
leben in der um dem umfang noch nie
gesehen und als er dann weiter ist durch
die straßen links und rechts
zerstörungen blieb noch einmal stehen
ist dann in sein auto und wenn
beobachtet hat bei der abfahrt von dem
team hat man seinen augen gesehen wie
sehr das in ihm gearbeitet hat das was
er dort ja sehen musste toll was bleibt
für dich von diesem besuch der ja nun
auch im vorfeld für so viele
irritationen gesorgt hatte der dann doch
von den ukrainern so sehr gewollt so
sehr gewünscht war was bleibt für dich
da am ende hängen
gut dass sie endlich daran und zu viert
kam also mal kommt draghi scholz und der
rumänische regierungschef johannes das
war ein starkes zeichen und man hat ja
in russland gesehen was das für
nervosität fast ausgelöst hat wie der
ministerpräsident gewütet hat das war
gut das andere ist ich finde mit seinem
besuch in japan wenn er das so an fast
wenn man das auch emotionalisiert wie
den bundeskanzler dann geht das auch mit
der verpflichtung einher dafür zu sorgen
dass so was im osten nicht in dem umfang
passieren kann wie im tier und das geht
nur wenn man genügend waffen liefert
also eine verpflichtung aus meiner sicht
für olaf scholz da mehr zu tun und auch
dafür zu sorgen dass das jetzt schnell
geht denn hier geht es wirklich um jeden
tag haben wir dürfen gespannt sein was
nach diesen ankündigungen jetzt
tatsächlich dann folgt paul danke für
den moment und
paris hat er dann auch noch die
gelegenheit mit den klitschko-brüdern
über diesen scholz besuch zu reden hören
wir da mal rein
gerade haben sie bundeskanzler oder
shorts getroffen jetzt bei uns im
internet via twitter oder bürgermeister
wladimir klitschko bruder vitali was für
ein druck hast du von olaf scholz gehabt
in dem halbstündigen gespräch ist sehr
glücklich zumal die sofort bundesweit
das ist eine symbolische bedeutung zumal
ich es nicht nur symbolisch
räumlichkeiten ich bin gekommen das
gedicht
der hauptwunsch und souveränem eine
etwas positiv wenn dieser status feinde
weil er die blumen machte noch einmal
die krone von bissing rosenkrieg das ist
ein wunsch von trainer
fischer familie zu werden bitterli
gleichzeitig ein thema wurde fast
ausgeklammert bei der pressekonferenz
mit dem präsidenten habt ihr mit olaf
scholz darüber gesprochen das thema
waffen dafür steht deutschland schwer in
der kritik das nicht genug ankommen was
ist dein eindruck kann das besser werden
oder will collatz nicht liefern oder so
viel liefern
durchstand virus informiert und will
durchdacht ist eine kruste in serie und
beschlüsse so feine seit jahren und
durch unterstufe nicht so schnell kommen
wir diese waffen was wir versprochen und
deswegen
bisherigen beteiligung seine lebenswelt
in frose aufwarten von unser bruder der
führung deswegen und haben schon gesagt
wir brauchen brauchen dringend immer
dabei war weil er
ist sehr wichtig ist sehr wichtig und
wir wissen diese verstehen wie
beteiligen nicht nur unsere landkreise
und städte die beteiligung werde in
europa wissen nicht wie weit wir weiter
aber auch von der berufsschule gleich
wir zum abschluss wenn du die gesamt
besuch gesehen hat dass bundeskanzler
werden er hat es getroffen hat euch
getroffen was glaubst du hast das mit
ihm gemacht er wurde ja lange kritisiert
dass er nicht hier war jetzt war die
hast das gefühl dass es bei ende hat
seine sicht auf die ukraine denn der
kanzler hat den kennst ihn aus hamburger
zeiten also bürgermeister war was hat
den eindruck gemacht hatte ich glaube es
war enorm wichtig dass herr
bundeskanzler in wien war wo das
kriegsverbrechen stattgefunden hat er
hat mit eigenen augen gesehen
wahrscheinlich nicht die toten körper
was wir gesehen haben als die
streitkräfte diese städte blüten städten
verlassen haben aber er hat gesehen die
zerstörung also wenn man das sieht und
das hat man schon gehört auch bei den
anderen premieren den nächsten
präsidenten der gruppe waren das hat
wahnsinn in bern druck was von eine
sinnlose zerstörung von leben und
infrastruktur stattgefunden hat und es
ist nur her und es ist ruhig aber gerade
während wir reden im osten und im süden
des landes laufend kämpfe brutale kämpfe
wir wollen das thema noch ein bisschen
vertiefen und zwar mit der gs um lenny
ist osteuropa experte schönen guten
morgen & morgen es sollte eine große
zeitenwende werden hatte olaf scholz
angekündigt hat er ihrer meinung nach
diesen besuch in der ukraine tatsächlich
für diese zeitenwende genutzt
in der ukraine hat man natürlich auf
diese gewartet und hat auch von diesem
besuch viel erwartet
vor allem die waffen die ankündigung
dass deutschland auch frankreich jetzt
endlich im großen stil die schweren
waffen welche die ukraine
im osten und südosten was die produkte
schon
gesagt haben ja brauchen da nach
unterschiedlichen angaben sterben an der
frontlinie im osten der ukraine täglich
also bis zu 100 soldaten der
ukrainischen armee also wir können diese
zahlen nicht reduzieren aber so 50 bis
100 soldaten an der front täglich zu
verlieren ist für die ukraine auf jeden
fall die verluste welche sehr
schmerzhaft sind und wenn wir hier
eine schlacht ziehen eine
materialschlacht wo die russen gegenüber
der ukraine stehen und sagen gut wir
verlieren ebenso 140 soldaten pro tage
will haben viel mehr davon das können
wir uns hertreiben und russland ist
keine demokratie russland kann damit
leben dass die soldaten was nach dort
fallen die ukraine ist eine demokratie
und kann sich das nicht leisten
also in diese situation brauchen wir
sofort die unterstützung und nicht im
august was vielleicht der fall sein kann
nicht im juli sondern so schnell wie
möglich weil jeder tag kostet und genau
das haben die ukraine von den
bundeskanzler scholz erwartet ob dieses
versprechen in der tat stattfand das
bezweifeln viele in der ukraine und
wiederum der besuch war sehr gut und
wichtig und gut und wichtig war es dass
die hier dass die dass die vier
staatschefs in diesen städten waren in
wien wo die frau die daten die russen
mehr stattfanden aber ob die er besucht
den erwarten
groß war da derartigen waren nach drei
monaten sehr hoch das bezweifle ich
gab es zumindest mal ein versprechen
sozusagen die ukraine als eu
beitrittskandidaten zu behandeln jetzt
eine große absichtserklärung von allen
vieren aber was bringt das der ukraine
tatsächlich jetzt
also diese
beitrittskandidaten status ist für die
ukraine wichtig und ich sag es schon
meinen kritischen kollegen ist wäre es
wäre strategisch gesehen falsch und
dramatisch falsch wenn die ukraine
gesagt hätten naja so wir setzen uns
auch den eu-kandidatenstatus das bringt
uns jetzt nichts und wir bestehen auf
waffen nein die ukraine braucht die
beiden sachen also die waffen die
ukraine zum sieg bringen können und den
beitrittskandidaten status das bringt
politisch das bringt in politisch vielen
das zeigt der bevölkerung dass es in der
tat auch in der situation der weg in die
europäische gemeinschaft offen bleibt
und das ist auch für russland ein signal
dass die europäischen länder die ukraine
nicht abschreiben dass die europäischen
länder darauf
darauf hoffen dass und sicher sind dass
die ukraine diesen weg noch weiter geht
wenn wir schauen was die ex präsident
roosevelt gesagt wer platzhalter für den
präsidenten putin mit wenig schrieb vor
ein paar tagen in seinem in seiner zelle
grant account er schrieb wir sind uns
gar nicht sicher ob die ukraine in zwei
jahren existiert das ist der traum
russlands
und der thrombus dass auch die
europäischen länder in der in der sich
äußern und sagen ja so über den status
können wir jetzt den treten weil wir
nicht sicher sind was sie die politische
realität dann bald aussieht nach europa
sagt ganz klar und deutlich wir sehen
die ukraine in der europäischen
gemeinschaft als ein mitgliedsland und
hier ist ihr kandidatenstatus für euch
also das ist wie die ukraine wie sich
aber natürlich ohne waffen ist diese
freude nur sehr kurz kurzfristig
danke schön für das gespräch
dank ihnen